welcome back to GameSpot's week-long
steam early access stravaganza video
games knowledge and fun Ivor host Chris
waters here to guide you through games
he can pay for and play today even
though they're still in development
today's destination is a lot of games
love space but not a lot of games focus
on getting to space as JFK the soviets
and martin gaston found out getting to
space is hard the only difference is
martin figured out his lesson playing
kerbal space program yeah that's the
only difference i am no good at building
things Christ I can barely assemble a
sandwich so I'm rubbish at kerbal space
program a game about constructing
spacefaring vessels and then flying them
around the solar system even after
playing it for a few hours I reckon it
would be easier to construct an actual
real-life spaceship out of old Star Trek
DVDs that it is to build one that can
land successfully on the bloody moon in
this game right now kerbal space program
is more of a sandbox adventure rather
than a game that has a sense of
overarching objective so most of the
time you'll be making your own fun and
accidentally killing your crew for the
50th time of today but recent patches
specifically note point2 to have added
in more structure incorporating R&D
elements and making the whole thing feel
more like you're the boss of an
enterprising yet incompetent space
program rather than just a rubbish
engineer and pilot kerbal space program
is such a huge simulation that it's
tough to say where it might end up in
the next few years although i'll
probably still be exploding two-thirds
of my ships on the trustee kerbal
launchpad the game is currently up to
version naught point 23 which shows just
how far it is from being in any way
finished but even now it's a fantastic
and unique experience as for me I'm
still trying to get to the moon and back
which pretty much makes me a beginner in
the universe of the game with more
advanced people heading out to explore
jewel in the loop
that kind of stuff can come later
because I've got my goal and one day my
poor in almost certainly doomed kerbals
will get a handful of you onto the
surface of that moon so you're in space
now what cruise to Alpha Centauri on a
spaceship you'll get a space drink in a
space bar with some space aliens get
real people we live in a post minecraft
world if you want to fly it you got to
craft it here's Rob handlery with space
engineers have you ever spent hours on a
lego ship just to see it thrown into a
wall and explode well if you're the type
that can pick up the pieces and start
over space engineers might be for you
this open-world space sandbox lets you
build enormous ships where the size is
limited to the time you put in calling
it minecraft in space ring some truth
but you don't just build ships in space
engineers you battle with them there's a
sense of grand scale space engineers as
aspiring towards mining resources to
build your ship is part of it but the
game at heart strikes deep with the
sci-fi fan it's early access community
has already posted pictures of some
incredible work your first shift will
most likely be in the scrap yard but the
drive to build another one never gets
thrown out and if the hours of work
spent building a failure ship frustrates
you smashing it to smithereens is a
great way to let some steam out space
engineers is moving in the right
direction but the current lack of
multiplayer makes your warship building
feel pointless multiplayer will make or
break space engineers until then well
you're gonna have to tough it out in a
cold quiet space
they say in space no one can hear you
scream but in the cramped twisting
corridors and tiny rooms of an ill
designed space station no one can't hear
you scream or talk to your mother-in-law
poop or anything Tom mcshay took a whack
at building a better base in space base
DF 9 let's hear what he thought a
chicken man moved into my base he's kind
of a braggart and his gang li arms are
downright creepy but he seems to have a
way with plants honestly there aren't
many roommate options when you're
setting up a space habitat after
constructing the necessities you know
things like oxygen tanks sleeping
quarters a bench press you just have to
cross your fingers that a passing alien
fancies moving into your boat your
citizenry spends time doing jumping
jacks and playing video games it might
even do something important if they feel
like it assign minors to collect
resources and technicians to maintain
your equipment our tenders help everyone
forget that their loved ones are
thousands of light-years away and if a
derelict ship is sniffing around send a
security team to politely fire laser
beams at the potential usurpers remember
it's not just any old space base it's
your space base you know how it's
supposed to be lonely in space well
that's unfortunately true here despite
how affable your people are they're just
not that much to do right now once you
build all the different rooms it's just
a matter of tinkering with decorations
and hoping you don't get caught in an
asteroid shower or maybe you welcome a
little chaos just look at them stomping
their feet to extinguish the flames how
precious it might be too early to take
the plunge on space base but keep it on
your radar
I hate to be the one to bring this party
crashing back down to earth but it's
over leave a comment and get out tune in
tomorrow for the next episode in our
week-long steam early access series but
seriously it's over we're done waters
out
you